just it's not good but it should be but
it's not it's Game of Thrones it's a
long history of romance not ending well
on this show hey everybody it's Charlie
We Need to Talk all about the big
betrayals of season eight gwendoline
christie and sophie turner were recently
talking about how it's going to be the
bloodiest season but also full of
betrayals in not necessarily the ones
you expect the show is slowly paying off
all the big prophecies and there's still
the most epic of betrayals that they
have not paid off primarily Daenerys Jon
Snow and Tyrion so we need to break it
down I'll mention some of the lesser
ones at the end of the video because I
mean full of betrayal implies that
everybody is going to betray everybody
else but I wanted to focus on the
biggest new one first so if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the Game of Thrones videos
we're getting ready for some new footage
later this year it's gonna be awesome
there's a new round of that 4k blu-ray
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video so when Sophie
Turner and gwyndolin Christie's say that
season 8 is going to be full of good
old-fashioned backstabbing that's not
just talking about Cersei backstabbing
the North by not helping them out at
their darkest hour literally and
metaphorically like the night king is
coming there's a big battle that's going
to be happening at Winterfell
Cersei in the season 7 finale basically
told Jaime she was just gonna sit this
one out see what happens if they make it
down here we'll deal with that later
there's still a lot of people that think
that when Tyrion met with Cersei during
the season 7 finale that he made a
secret deal with her and we'll find out
about that during season 8 but I think
that moment was really just about him
getting her to try and see reason
we're family listen to your family
member and Cersei just wasn't having it
but there is evidence that Jon Snow in
Tyrion will betray Daenerys during
season 8 as part of the fulfillment of
the prophecy of three betrayals so this
is what it says three fires you must
like one for life one for death and one
to love three mounts you must ride one
to bed and one to dread and want to love
three treasons you will know once for
blood once for gold and once for love
the three people associated with the
prophecy and those betrayals are Khal
Drogo
hizdahr and then Jon Snow he's the
betrayal for love
so a couple years ago before we got
season seven a lot of people felt like
Daenerys would come to Westeros she
would become Jon Snow's Nissa Nissa and
he would have to like literally plunge
his sword into her like long claw to
create Lightbringer so that he could
become a Zora hi but the important thing
to remember when you think about
prophecies from the books is the
metaphorical way in which the show has
approached them probably the best
example is the way they recontextualize
the prophecy of azor Ahai where they say
well it's high Valyrian that's
gender-neutral meaning that it could be
a man or a woman in what the show has
done has presented a version wherein Jon
Snow engineers together you know man and
woman are both the Song of Ice and Fire
just as there's this supernatural Song
of Ice and Fire
between the red God in the night King
the legend of how Azure high will Forge
light bringer to save the world goes
like this to fight the darkness azor
Ahai needed to forge a hero's sword he
labored for 30 days and 30 nights until
it was done however when he went to
temper it in water the sword broke he
was not one to give up easily
so he started over the second time he
took 50 days and 50 nights to make the
sword even better than the first to
temper it this time he captured a lion
and drove the sword into its heart but
once more the steel shattered the third
time with a heavy heart for he knew
beforehand what he must do to finish the
blade he worked for a hundred days and
nights until it was finished this time
he called for his wife Nissa Nissa and
asked her to bear her breast he drove
the sword into her breast her soul
combining with the steel of the sword
creating Lightbringer so remember the
metaphorical way the show approaches
these book prophecies think of azor Ahai
forging the blade by plunging it into
his wife miss anissa's heart is Jon Snow
betraying Daenerys over one of her
dragons metaphorically speaking the
dragons are Daenerys his heart so
betraying Daenerys over one of her
dragons to forge Lightbringer to
effectively defeat the night king and
save the realm also remember
metaphorically speaking the Dragons or
the true light bringer like beric does
have a flaming sword but it's just
regular castle-forged steel with a
little bit of wild
for effects what they've been building
towards is the dragons being the true
light bringer azure hi tried three
separate times to create light bringer
think of what happened with Jon Snow
during season seven they go north of the
wall they fail the blade shatters so
think of Viserion is the first attempt
he tried again 50 days and 50 nights
this time this time trying to plunge it
into a lion it implies that Daenerys is
gonna lose another one of her dragons
during the next Battle of Winterfell
against the night king in his army so we
still know that there's a big battle
happening down at King's Landing so
think of the third attempt of the
prophecy as this big final battle down
at King's Landing with Cersei so you get
the most epic of betrayals even though
it's not necessarily malicious in its
intent there would be no other way but
making decisions in battle that will
knowingly lead to the death of Daenerys
as children her dragons is still a
betrayal of sorts so I also think that
tyrion is part of this too because while
he may not have made a special deal with
Cersei during the season 7 finale think
about it this way Tyrion is the most
clever person in the north now and he
knows his sister Cersei is never going
to make peace with Daenerys while her
dragons still exist if you're flying
around with weapons of mass destruction
that the enemy does not have there's no
way that they're ever going to trust
what you say so even though I think that
Jon Snow is the fulfillment of that
betrayal for love as part of her three
betrayals I think that tyrion is also
part of that tangentially - even though
he doesn't have the same romantic love
for Daenerys that Jon Snow does so while
Tyrians betrayal wouldn't be quite so
epic I think that he wouldn't hesitate
to support Jon Snow in a decision that
would knowingly lead to the death of the
Dragons if Cersei were to tell him that
she would make peace if he helped get
rid of the Dragons
so while Jon Snow and Tyrion would never
knowingly kill one of the Dragons
intentionally to hurt Daenerys think of
it as sending a soldier into battle
knowing that they're probably not going
to come back like you make that call
so Daenerys even though she knows that
that's probably the only way things
could have gone down would view that is
the most epic of betrayals you set my
child into battle now he's dead I have
no more children I've already done a
couple videos about how the story is
foreshadowing Daenerys becoming pregnant
with Jon Snow's child
but for now she still thinks that the
dragons are her only children and that
she'll never have another one so right
now we can view that as one of the most
epic betrayals of the season there's
still several other lesser ones I've
already done videos about Jamie
betraying Cersei by literally killing
her
Cersei betraying Jaime by making
decisions that lead to his death like
they mutually lead to each other's
deaths of a fashion tinfoil aspect of
that is Aria wearing Jaime's face after
he dies so you get this crazy three-way
fulfillment of the valonqar prophecy but
then you also have lesser betrayals like
the North betraying Jon Snow because of
his heritage in his relationship with
Daenerys Sansa betraying Daenerys to the
Lords of the north all of that stuff I
think will be relatively inconsequential
because of what they're dealing with
like first couple of episodes the Lords
of the north find out that Jon Snow's a
Targaryen it blows their minds it causes
all this drama Jon Snow learns that he's
related to Daenerys so that creates all
kinds of weird feelings we eventually
find out that she's pregnant it
complicates things but I think some of
those moments won't get nearly as much
screen time as what's going on with the
Dragons the fight with the night king in
the fight with Cersei remember Cersei is
still sort of like the main villain next
to the night king on the show so any big
epic betrayal involving her Daenerys
dragons and Jon Snow and Tyrion will get
way more screen time than any of the
other betrayals but let me know in the
comments what is the most epic of
betrayals you're hoping to see during
season eight congratulations to the
giveaway winner from my last big video
Matt H please email me on the back end
of my channel so I can get your contact
details I'll name a new winner when I
post new Game of Thrones leave your
requests in the comments below
but click here for more brand new season
8 and click here to learn all about
what's going on with the spin-off show
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight